[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to be doing
something very out of the norm for this
channel and that's recording my screen
getting sorted into my hogwarts house
this has been heavily requested since i
started the channel so i hope it doesn't
disappoint for those unaware
visitingworld.com formerly pottermore
provides harry potter fans with a
wizarding passport that is a place where
your unique hogwarts house wand and
patronus are all recorded the site also
offers its users different quizzes in
which they're able to find out these
things over the next few weeks i'm going
to be recording my screen and going
through these quizzes starting with
perhaps the largest quiz of all the
hogwarts sorting ceremony the primary
function of the sorting hat at hogwarts
is to assign new students to one of the
four houses gryffindor hufflepuff
ravenclaw or slytherin the hat is a
sentient being that originally belonged
to godric gryffindor to perform its task
the hat uses legitimacy which is the art
of magically navigating through a
person's mind the hat will navigate the
layers of the wearer's mind and after
careful consideration announce its
decision loudly so that all can hear
essentially it sorts you into a house
based on how closely you resemble one of
the four founders if the hat senses
great bravery gryffindor is a likely
choice if the hat senses great
intelligence ravenclaw is a likely
choice if the hat senses that someone is
a hard worker hufflepuff is a likely
choice and finally if the hat senses
that someone is hungry for power then
slytherin is a likely choice now since
we don't have access to the real sorting
hat unfortunately we're going to have to
rely on the wizarding world sorting quiz
which i think does a pretty good job
i've taken this quiz numerous times in
the past and i've always flip-flopped
between two houses in particular however
it's been quite a while now i'm curious
to see where i sit at the moment be
forewarned i freeze up a lot when it
comes to live content and a much better
scripted but i did my best before you
watch the rest of the video and my
sorting pause the video for a second and
comment your guess for which house i'm
in down below also be sure to include
your house and whether or not you've
taken this quiz without further ado
here's my hogwarts sorting ceremony
okey dokey time to get sorted
discover your house
[Music]
dusk
you and two friends need to cross a
bridge guarded by a river troll who
insists on fighting one of you before he
will let all of you pass do you
volunteer to fight
attempt to confuse the troll into
letting all three of you pass without
fighting
suggest that all three of you should
fight without telling the troll
or suggest drawing lots to decide which
of you will fight
um
i think i'm gonna go with this one
which of the following do you find most
difficult to deal with
loneliness
boredom hunger
or being
being ignored
or cold
maybe
maybe loneliness i feel like
the others aren't that bad
loneliness
what are you most looking forward to
learning at hogwarts
all about magical creatures and how to
befriend care for them
flying on a broomstick
apparition and this apparition being
able to materialize and de-materialize
at will
secrets about the castle transfiguration
turning one object into another object
hexes and jinxes
every area of magic i can
yeah this one
which of the following would you most
hate people to call you
ignorant
selfish
ordinary
cowardly
[Music]
maybe ignorant
yeah
if you were attending hogwarts which pet
would you choose to take with you
cats toads owls
i
would definitely go with cat
if you were attending hogwarts which pet
same question so which type of cat
ginger cat white cat
siamese cat tabby cat
black cat
four boxes are placed before you which
would you try and open
the gleaming jet black box with a silver
locking key marked with a mysterious
rune you know to be the mark of merlin
the small pewter box unassuming in plane
with a scratched message upon it that
reads i open only for the worthy
the small tortoise shell box embellished
with gold inside which some small
creature seems to be squeaking
or the ornate golden casket standing on
clawed feet whose inscription warns that
both secret knowledge and unbearable
temptation lie within
[Music]
this is a tough one
i think this one i mean merlin is
you know purportedly the most powerful
wizard of all time so if it's got the
mark of merlin on it then that's good
for me
white or black
black
[Music]
the sorting hat is ready to make its
decision
[Music]
i'm a slytherin okay
so pride ambition cunning you probably
know that some of slytherin's most
renowned members include severus snape
and bellatrix are strange but did you
know merlin himself was a slytherin or
that according to legend the ribbon of
her first class order of merlin is green
to reflect his hogwarts house
a message from your prefect
congratulations i'm prefect gemma farley
and i'm delighted to welcome you to
slytherin house our emblem is the
serpent the wisest of creatures our
house colors are emerald green and
silver and our common room lies behind a
concealed entrance down in the dungeons
as you'll see its windows look out into
the depths of the hogwarts lake we often
see the giant squid swooshing by and
sometimes more interesting
creatures and sometimes more interesting
creatures we like to feel that our
hangout has the aura of a mysterious
underwater shipwreck
and there you have it slytherin did you
get it right the two that i generally
flip-flop between are gryffindor and
slytherin so i can't say i'm too
surprised i know they're opposing houses
but they do actually border each other
quite closely in a lot of ways which is
probably why historically we've seen a
sorting hat waiver between these two
houses in particular i like the quiz but
one of my issues with it is that it's a
little bit short iq tests and
personality tests like myers-briggs are
comprised of hundreds of questions which
i think provides a more accurate result
i'd love to see that same sort of
specificity and accuracy dedicated to a
harry potter quiz maybe i'll make one
anyway that's it for today's video stay
tuned for my wand and patronus quizzes
in the near future until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you